so as of recording this it's the first
January 2014 so happy New Year everybody
even though I'm probably going to upload
this like two or three days after this
so expect this video 2nd 3rd 4th of
January something like that but
basically yesterday I was outside
lighting fireworks the entire day and we
slept over at my aunts house was a busy
night busy day today come home have lots
of Skype calls and [ __ ] it's
basically kind of tired and it's kind of
in a long two days for me without barely
any sleep and without going to sleep
nice so um yeah Here I am it's 9 o'clock
January the 1st and I'm recording and
let's play episode 8 so yeah let's do
this I figured I don't know I haven't
really got I haven't really got any
feedback on this yet but do you guys
like time-lapse is better than real-time
footage or not because it doesn't really
matter to me but I do kind of want to do
what people want to see the only problem
that I already see right now with this
plan is that there's going to be a lot
of lag yup nice yeah this is kind of
unbearable this is basically what I have
to put up with the entire time so you so
you better just have lots of respects
for me lots of respects and and and very
much blood ones because this is very
hard work that I'm doing here for you
yes it's not a lot of lag in here it
depends on on the direction of the
camera you know because if I face that
way with all the buildings and [ __ ] the
game goes berserk but if I face that way
and go a little bit over here zoom in a
little bit games almost fine almost not
quite because I can see a 20 FPS mark
max 21 minimum 16 15 Oh nuts 23 25 oh
good good so anyway let's get to work
here yeah some quick path work might as
well make a little bit of
all of it so this is how you make paths
lots of people have been asking me how
you make paths you're so good at it and
I'm like here just be so fret huh good
at my [ __ ] no but yeah you can't explain
that it's hard to do it because um I
don't really know what I should say like
if somebody would ask me in real life on
how do I make good pass I just be like
oh you take of path SATs and you place
them on the ground and bam but yeah
that's basically how clueless I am I
just mess around really like there's so
many people think that I am serious when
it comes to rollercoaster country I am
NOT roller-coaster country is just one
creative thing and I like to do but 99%
of the time I'm just messing around and
I always just hope for the best
and as of now at this park it's turning
out quite nice and I'm happy it does but
there's nothing planned about this I'm
just messing around same goes for these
paths but the thing is I do have lots of
experience way too much I mean lots of
experience it's not even possible
lots of experiences so much experience
very rollercoaster in three so amazed
but yeah basically what I wanted to say
I have a lot of experience and that's
basically how you get good at this doing
random [ __ ] you just have to know what
you kinda can do and what you can't do
that's all there is to it it's not
something secret it's not something you
can learn in particular it's just
getting used to the game knowing what
you can do is certain stuff I know this
sounds very I know the sun's very vague
and probably not even helpful at all but
that that's how it is I mean I've been
playing this game for I think it came
out in 2004 and that's when I got it so
almost 10 years and yeah I've built up
quite a lot of experience in that time I
know that I started my youtube channel
somewhere in
January or February in 2010 so that's
about four years as well so uh yeah I've
been in this for quite a while although
I would say that there are lots of
people who are well better than me
that's how I think you know the thing
with roller coaster country I wouldn't
is that I wouldn't say that there's a
certain good or bad of which you can
really say okay that's good and that's
bad because it's of course it's
subjective it's an opinion and it
differs to everybody but there's also
lots of different styles and ways people
can be creative within this game it's
like comparing apples with pears it's
what they say in Holland it's basically
you can't come you can't compare that
especially with roller cascoon three
when you've got people creating parks
you've got people creating tracks you've
got people creating fireworks stuff
pyrotechnics is actually quite a big
thing in here people making the custom
scenery and CTRs let's not forget about
those and yeah lots of talented people
in this community and you can't just say
this this guy is better than the other
one or girl because there are a few
girls oh yeah I think because
everybody's good in their own right so
um everybody everybody is good everybody
is a winner
everybody's a king at this game you're
all awesome if you subscribe to me by
the way back to this if I would just do
paths in here it would be kind of boring
so I wanna have some buildings in there
but uh I can always do that later on so
uh let's forget about cuts although I
would like to do some diagnol buildings
in here so I'll just leave this like
that
I won't at any other path work to that
well I could add some full tile things
except they're only on full tile
placement
that kind of sucks but basically what
I'm planning here well not really
planning what I hoping I can maybe go
off is a series of small buildings in
here like I did with what's called a gun
Buzzard for example
yeah I guess that could work out so yeah
this this is it for a pass and by the
way with paths always make sure to have
these curves little curves like these
always make it look a little bit like
less like it's on the grid and less like
it's a stupid game and more like it's
actually real life because who's ever
seen straights paths in real life I mean
come on
and then there are the details details
are important look at this
I'm using alpha paths all right let me
well no I'll keep it on basically what I
do is I take this brown little color
thing blah blah blah blah brush it all
over the place so it looks more cool
yeah I think I've missed a few spots
here and here and then I go to the sides
and a little bit of this darker soil
texture I mean it's not that much of a
difference but it adds a little bit of
that idea that there is a well edge kind
of thing also it adds the idea with
shadow ambient occlusion things because
I don't have any inter clusion and I
need to come up with little tricks to
make some contrasts in places way don't
necessarily have contrast so yeah you
can do that like that you can see that
effects very subtly huh wait that's a
bit too extreme now and then the second
step would be borders because I'm I will
not leave these paths just like this I
want some stone borders in between so
these Luke extra like they're sidewalks
things I mean they're not really
sidewalks this is not really a road I
digress I need some planters for that
shy guys planters like I'm going to be
honest with you guys in all the time
that I've been on YouTube this is
probably one of the most requested
things what do I use for the borders
with my paths well here it is shy guys
planners great SATs
there's also planners to also great
hi guys great guy okay that's it for
shoutouts and it's got its got all the
pieces that that path cover set hat or
rather that path cover set had all the
pieces that this one has because this is
probably one of the oldest sets that I
use I know
shy guy sets are generally pretty old
and this one is like one one of the
Stone Age roller coastering three but
it's still great let's see the a and B
diagonal straight curves are always kind
of tricky to work with but they look
good so I would really recommend you
using them legs not all all that bad
so yeah that's you know the wave piece
of [ __ ] now
lights let's vote he fought him fought
him whatever he's called I think it's a
German guy
what however you pronounce it whatever
he has some cool lights and voting's
lights at oops I forgot a little tile on
here no but I'll get back to that later
here's some cool lights like these and
they're pretty swell so I placed them in
my parks because 14 is a cool guy like
that and they kind of fit the classical
theme in a way I don't know how I think
so but they're cool whatever
let's get back to planners because I
this just just hurts my eyes
it hurts my eyes whenever I see
something like that so you know
now that's a few things left to do first
of all we go to benches here Thirteen's
bench get there is again there he is
again he has nice little benches and
we're going to place one of those here
and here so people can look at the
coaster and here because when it comes
to furniture bath furniture especially
you onion of a classical theme there
cannot be enough benches I repeat there
cannot be enough benches
never ever just like they cannot be
enough crunch rubbery there's never
enough benches I mean go to Paris it's
benches everywhere it's pretty much
bench fest in here and whenever you got
a boring path and you don't know what to
do to make it a little bit nicer just
throw benches all over the place you
know it's one of those easy fixes for
anything Oh
benches I love you almost as much Grudge
shrubbery so I don't know how you
pronounce this one but they're all nice
so it doesn't really matter which one
you take I just want to make sure that I
take one bench for the entire Park
except for a few picnic places or stuff
but that should be kind of you know
common sense shouldn't have the same
bench like ten thousand times in one
point that's kind of ridiculous alright
now the last thing and this is well it's
second to last thing it's last thing
when it comes to new paths it's well if
you do it like I do ye olde brick
because though short not walk on a
person without bricks because bricks are
[ __ ] fancy that's why I love this
texture now this is glitching but screw
that that's not a problem
nobody's going to notice so yeah
I'm too lazy to fix that and look for
the right piece
okay so that's basically how you make a
path now there's one thing one tiny
thing I need to do fences you you must
never leave your path without fences
because that's just stupid like people
could just walk to the coaster over here
by my lalalalalala commit suicide
seppuku all over the place
explosions everybody dies and nobody's
happy so um you don't want that to
happen so I'm got stationed gyms fancy
and ice station gyms fencing where you
at here here it is it has some it has
some swell fences in it and his cool war
and it's all cool and it has a brick
texture and once again it conforms to
the paths and shyguys planners and it
all conforms and everybody's happy
so where's Dan peace I can O be oh yeah
that works I don't want to be using the
same fences all over the place because
that gets boring you shouldn't do that
always mix them up a little because I've
got this wooden like fence in here which
is pretty cool and then the combination
fence in here which I guess planners
wanted to and other stuff and this cool
little medieval battlements thing which
I used for that it still looks pretty
cool but again I digress diagonal or
always listen to music usually when I
play rock I scream 3 well not always
usually if like I said I listen to music
random mixes of EEM and stuff stuff that
oh we usually put in my let's play
episodes for the time lapses that's the
kind of music I listen to as well
sometimes pop music I don't really like
modern-day pop music I'm I'm more
talking or bouts rock from the
ladies seventies 90s 90s I love the 90s
and yeah just a few trucks nowadays
that's just a few artists that released
tracks these days that I'd like
I mean u2's kind of cool mmm who else in
school want nobody no no just some one
day flies there are always school
trainees okay and $1 actually actually
your songs are really good the only
problem is that people play it too much
people get too obsessed over it I mean
it's good music but it's still pop music
so it's still commercial stuff it's
still like products basically but then
again it's a good product
but um fences fences no this is nice see
this is this one fence throughout this
spot with the coaster looks pretty cool
same fence all around the only problem
with this fence at is that you have
separate walls and wall posts so it
takes a little bit more work so it takes
a little bit more time and if you're a
lazy ass you probably don't want to use
this sets but I'm going for the final
results so I'm using this up just
because it looks nice I mean the fact
that as separate walls and wall posts
also makes it a little bit better
because you can use it for different
things you can be creative with it and
use the posts for buildings I think I've
used up I think I've done that before
and also use the walls as edges for
buildings and stuff I mean the best
thing in rolek you scream through to do
what's wrong with this by the way it's
just to come up with here on own ideas
on how to use this at because really you
don't have to use a set the way the
creator taught you to actually if I
think most creators of customs you know
we like to see people use their sets in
a creative way
so yeah just see what you can do with
SATs and think outside the box is also a
tip I would give
so yeah that's the fence um is there
anything I also still need to do you
know what we've we haven't had a time
lapse yet I can do that so
they say
we'll be
stay till it's over
myself out of the ocean form fading line
through never saw myself rise with the
water they thought they could keep it on
the breath and watch being around food
only
Hey
you are so
Oh
alright so this part of the park is now
finished and I had planned on making a
little farm ish windmill thing and I
guess I kind of succeeded in that it's a
little bit over the top I guess because
there's there's a temple and little I
didn't even know what the [ __ ] that
building is thing but all in all it
looks pretty cool and it's foliage
around it and other stuff I think it
should be alright and now that camera is
glitching I don't know what the hell
this thing's thinking oh like spike
thanks for that but yeah so basically I
took like over 20 minutes to do this
episode so hope you enjoy this one
you've probably waited too long for this
one as well but I need to keep my
episodes and around 10 minutes so I [ __ ]
yeah I'll pay attention to that in the
future but for now this is it for this
episode and see you next one bye